Speaker 1: An extraordinarily disturbing story
broke over the weekend about the failed former
president Donald Trump. And, you know, one
of the things I said was it's going to take
us a long time to learn the full scope of the
danger that happened during those very dark four
years in American history. And we are learning
something new almost every single week. The new
report is per Donald Trump's former secretary of
Defense, Mark Esper. Trump Wanted to bomb Mexico.
You'd think. Well, but, David, there must be
more. Yeah, there's more. But that's basically the
story. Trump wanted to send missiles to Mexico to
attack the drug cartels and then maybe just kind
of like, say, it wasn't us and pretend he didn't
do it and be like, I don't know, maybe, you know,
maybe it was Canada. I don't really know. Here is
Mark Esper on 60 Minutes last night telling this
disturbing story.
Speaker 4: The president
pulls me aside on at least a couple of occasions
and suggests that maybe we have the US military
shoot missiles into Mexico, shoot.
Speaker 5: Missiles into Mexico for.
Speaker 4: What he would say to to go after the
cartels. And we would have this private discussion
where I'd say, Mr. President, I understand.
Speaker 1: Mr. President, sir. Bad idea.
Speaker 4: The motive, because he was very serious
about dealing with drugs in America. I get that.
We all understand. But I had to explain to him
we can't do that. It would violate international
law. It would be terrible for our neighbors to the
south. It would impact us in so many. Here's the.
Speaker 1: Reasons why bombing Mexico is a bad.
Speaker 4: Idea is why don't we do this instead?
Speaker 5: You politely push back on the
idea. Did President Trump really say no
one would know it was us?
Speaker 4: Yes. Yes,
he said that. And I just thought.
Speaker 1: Let's paint the missiles,
the color of the Guatemalan flag. And then
they'll say with this must have been Guatemala.
Speaker 4: Fanciful, right? Because of course
it would be. I was reluctant to tell the
story because I think I thought people
won't believe this, that they'll think.
Speaker 1: Well. So he was reluctant to
tell it until he could make money from it,
at which point he put it in a book. And all of
these guys and gals do that. They all do that.
And that we've talked about before.
Speaker 4: I'm just making it up. And
folks in in Trump's orbit will will dispute it.
And then I was having dinner after the election
in 2020 with a fellow cabinet member.
And and he said to me, he goes, you know,
remember that time when President Trump suggested
you shoot missiles into Mexico? And I said to
him, You you heard that? He goes, Oh, yeah, I
couldn't believe it. And I couldn't believe how
how well you managed and talked him down from
that. And at that moment, I knew I got to write
the story because I at least have one witness
who will verify that this really did happen.
Speaker 1: Now, Trump is not denying this, and
we're going to get to that in a little bit.
But think about this. What in a sense, we're
a super progressive country, right? We elected
the first completely unqualified,
dangerously psychopathic, narcissistic,
cognitively compromised president. Now, maybe we
didn't, but there's probably there's been others
not in the United States. But this has to be on
the top ten list of of wildest ideas. I mean,
we've got he he wanted to nuke a hurricane.
He wanted to inject bleach to kill COVID,
bombing Mexico, flushing presidential records down
the toilet, eating presidential records, saying
we're going to get Mexico to pay for a wall across
the entire southern border. Yeah, what? I don't
know exactly what else would be on the top ten
list, but this absolutely would. And just as we
predicted, every week, we learned the presidency
was even more dangerous than we ever knew at the
time. And by the way, and this is where I want
to go next, Trump is not denying that he wanted
to bomb Mexico, which means he did want to do it.
And that's what I want to discuss with you next.